la nation dit madame la parole est à
monsieur olivier dassault merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
ce premier miss en 2014 votre ministre
des affaires étrangères prométhée
d'accueillir 100 millions de touristes
étrangers en france
votre gouvernement manie avec
enthousiasme les effet d'annonce mais
dans les échos reste-t-il c'est la chute
trop de touristes manquent à l'appel
cette année bien sûr les attentats
participe au sentiment d'insécurité mais
comment expliquez vous que le premier
pays visité au monde soit seulement au
53e rang des dépenses moyennes par
voyageur les premières victimes se sont
l'hôtellerie la restauration c'est eux
qui payent l'addition paris ferait
recettes il les agressions et les vols
n'étaient pas en nette augmentation
si l'amoncellement des ordures n'est
crétinier pas la carte postale
quel féerie lundi vous avez annoncé de
nouvelles propositions pour sécuriser
les sites les plus visités
comptez vous renforcer les peines à
l'égard des délinquants haïssant dans
ces zones où allez vous trouver les 43
millions d'euros promis est-ce dans les
50 milliards supplémentaires prélevés
sur les ménages et les entreprises
et puis la grande oubliée la grande
oubliée c'est la france le plus beau
royaume après celui du ciel disait
grotius legrand ignorer ce président et
au patrimoine vivant de nos villes et de
nos villages pouvez par exemple mérite
qu'on s'y arrête pour découvrir son
horloge astronomique sa galerie sa
galerie d'à tapisserie et 10 millions
supplémentaires dégagés pour la
promotion de la carte de france sont
loin d'être suffisant à elle seule la
catalogne dépenses quatre fois plus pour
attirer les touristes et même stimuler
les baigneurs alors la france est belle
lorsqu'elle déroule ses atouts son
histoire ses talents sa culture
soutenons sa destination nous y serons
tous gagnants
merci la parole est en hausse et andré
vallini secrétaire d'état chargée du
développement et de la francophonie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député d'assaut la baisse de
fréquentation internationale
enregistrée cette année par le secteur
du tourisme est important de vous l'avez
dit elle tient à plusieurs facteurs au
premier rang desquels le terrorisme
évidemment vous l'avez dit aussi je vais
aussi citer les médias et les réseaux
sociaux qui ont abondamment relayé des
actes de délinquance qui visaient des
touristes étrangers notamment asiatiques
et cela a nuit bien sûr à notre
attractivité dans ces pays
face à ce problème le gouvernement agit
bien sûr contre la délinquance pour la
sécurité avec bernard cazeneuve et jean
jacques urvoas et le gouvernement est
fortement mobilisée sur la question du
tourisme c'est le sens des annonces
interview de septembre dernier à l'issue
du comité interministériel un paquet
total de 43 millions d'euros a été
annoncé dont plus de 15 millions seront
prévus pour la sécurité des touristes
dans les lieux touristiques les salles
de spectacle et les transports publics
ces sommes vont permettre d'abonder le
fonds interministériel de prévention de
la délinquance pour renforcer la
vidéosurveillance
elles vont permettre aussi d'aborder le
fond d'urgence pour le spectacle vivant
j'ajoute que des structures de
coordination sécurité tourisme vont être
mises en place dans chaque département
sous l'autorité des préfets en lien avec
les professionnels tourisme l'enjeu
c'est de conserver à la france
vous l'avez dit sa place de première
destination mondiale d'accroître les
recettes touristiques
c'est pourquoi jean marc ayrault et
matthias fekl réuniront le 17 novembre
prochain les professionnels et tous les
acteurs des territoires lors de la
deuxième conférence annuelle du tourisme